I just want to bring you some more
breaking news from Israel we're hearing
uh via news agencies uh this evening
that seven people have been wounded in
what's being described as a terror
attack at Tel aviv's Promenade
um that's the very latest that we're
hearing on this latest attack in Tel
Aviv we've got
um some words from an Israeli
spokesperson a police spokesperson
saying the Israel police received a
report of two injured people on queefman
Street the circumstances of the incident
are being investigated but as far as we
know the very latest is that seven
people have been wounded and too
seriously
in uh this terror attack we believe that
Tel aviv's Promenade this is from the
foreign Ministry in Israel we'll of
course keep you updated should we get
further information on that story